ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH. BONTA
BRO BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DEEP.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMóN OWN
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK. QUIRK
SILVA RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEEN
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND PATTY OSHA
RIVER KNOWS TO. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A MOMENT OF REFLECTION. WHEN
I CONSIDER THOSE THAT HAVE
INSPIRED ME TO PURSUE A LIFE OF
SERVICE THERE ARE TRAITS I FEEL
THEY ALL POSSESS. THE BELIEVE
IN THE INNATE GOODNESS OF
HUMANITY. AND THE PRECIOUSNESS
OF LIFE AND THE HOPE TO MAKE
THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE. I
THINK THAT ALL TO MENTORS SHARE
THE SAME AWARENESS OF LIFE AS
THE MOST NOBLE LEADERS AND
GREATER SPIRITUAL TEACHERS
THROUGHOUT HUMAN HISTORY. IT IS
THIS. WHAT WE DO ONLY FOR
OURSELVES DIES WITH US IT WILL
BE FORGOTTEN. WHAT WE DO FOR
OTHERS WILL RIPPLE ON IN BE
REMEMBERED. LET US BE INSPIRED
BAR MENTORS LEADERS IN
SPIRITUAL TEACHERS TO SEE THE
INNATE GOODNESS OF HUMANITY.
BELIEVE IN THE PRECIOUSNESS OF
LIFE. AND DOES NEVER STOP
TRYING TO MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE FOR WHAT WE DO
ONLY FOR OURSELVES DIES WITH US
AND WILL BE FORGOTTEN. WHAT WE
DO FOR OTHERS WILL RIPPLE ON
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND BE
REMEMBERED. NAMA ME DOWN SAID
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS. THANK YOU
REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AS SHE LEADS US
IN THE PLEDGE WAS PITCH DARK
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALINAS OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
WHICH IS. OUR THANK YOU YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY
NOVEMBER TWELFTH 2019% TO THE
PROVISIONS OF GENERAL FIFTY
NINE THE FOLLOWING US ON THE
JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY REGULAR SESSION WAS
PRINTED WHILE ASSEMBLY WAS AN
INTERIM STUDY RECESS THE POINT
COMMUNICATION WAS PRESENTED BY
THE ASSISTANT CHIEF CLERK IN
ORDER RENDON THERE'RE CALDERON
MOVES AND MR FLORA SECONDS AT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TRINITARIAN PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JORDAN
CUNNINGHAM. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SERVE ON TASKS
AND LEVINE
. MEMBERS ADDING TO
THE ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PHILLIP CHEN. MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TO ALLOW THE SPEAKER TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY AND AT THE
WHAT ROSTRUM. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOM FONG
HOLDEN PATTERSON TO SPEAK ON
INDETERMINATE MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER A. B.
TWELVE SIXTY THREE LOW AND AB
SIXTY SIXTY LOW. FROM THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FIFTY SIX. TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO NOTICE
BILLS PENDING RECEIPT. TO ALLOW
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THEIR
HEARING ON TUESDAY JANUARY
FOURTEENTH. AB TWELVE SIXTY
THREE LOW PENDING WE WERE FOR A
FROM THE RULES COMMITTEE AND AB
SIXTEEN SIXTEEN LOW PENDING RE
REFER ALL. FROM OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND TO ALLOW THE
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THEIR
HEARING ON TUESDAY JANUARY
FOURTEENTH. AB THREE TWENTY
FIVE RAMOS PENDING RE REFER ALL
FROM JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SB
SIX NINETY NINE GRAYSON PENDING
RE REFER OFTEN MAKING A FINANCE
COMMITTEE. AB NINE OH FOUR CHAO
PENDING WE WERE FOR A FROM THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE AND A.
B. TWELVE SIXTY THREE LOW
PENDING RE REFER ALL FROM THE
BUSINESS. AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE- I ALSO ASKED TO
ALLOW THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THEIR
HEARING ON WEDNESDAY. JANUARY
FIFTEENTH A. B. SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE WICKS PENNY WE WERE FOR
ALL FROM THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
AB NINE FIFTY TING AND BLOOM.
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AND A.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BONTA
PENDING REFERRAL. FROM THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE AND TO ALLOW THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE. AB FORTY TING FROM
THEIR HEARING ON WEDNESDAY
JANUARY FIFTEENTH PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MISTER
SPEAKER SET A LOT. IF YOU DON'T
MIND REPEATING IT ALL BACK TO
ME I'D APPRECIATE IT JUST MAKE
SURE YOU GOT . I WILL PASS
ON THAT MISTER CALDERON SEE NO
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER
. MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY. MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER GIBSON
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER SHOULD
RESIST RIGOR MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MY GUESS WHO
IS SEATED IN THE GALLERY TODAY
THERE ARE A GROUP OF SIXTY
YOUTH PARTICIPATING IN THE VERY
FIRST YOUTH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
PROJECT SPONSORED BY THE LIGHT
OF THE WORLD SURGEON MY
DISTRICT. MANY OF THEM WILL BE
GROW UP TO BE FUTURE LEADERS WE
WELCOME THE TO THE CAPITAL
MEMBERS YOU PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME I GUESS. THE STATE
.
MEMBERS WE PLEASE HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY NINE. H. R. SIXTY EIGHT
BY THE SPEAKER
. PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS MEMBERS. YEAH. THE
CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RENDON RELATIVE
TO THE ELECTION OF OFFICERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION
MISTER SPEAKER YOU MAILED IN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MISTER SPEAKER I OFFER
HOUSE RESOLUTION NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT TO DESIGNATE TO OF THE
NON MEMBER OFFICERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY THE REMAINING PORTION
OF THE 200-019-2000 TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION THEY ARE SUPER
MARKER AS CHIEF CLERK ANNALISA
BUCKLEY AS CHIEF SERGEANT OF
ARMS. THE CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY PERFORMS THE ROLE OF
PARLIAMENT AND OVERSEES THE
BILLS AND RECORDS OF THE HOUSE
THE CHIEF SERGEANT OF ARMS IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PRESERVING
ORDER AND DECORUM IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH OUR HOUSE RULES
AS A PICK OFFICE SURE TO WORK
IN CONJUNCTION WITH A BLONDE
WOMAN AGENCIES TO PROVIDE FOR
OUR DAY TO DAY SAFETY. SU ANNA
LISA BUCKLEY ARE WELL QUALIFIED
FOR THE OFFICES TO WHICH THEY
ARE APPOINTED I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
LAW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR SIXTY EIGHT TO
CONFIRM SU PARKER AS CHIEF
CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
ALYSSA BUCKLEY AS STEVE CHIEF
SERGEANT AT ARMS OF THE
ASSEMBLY. THE APPOINTMENTS
TODAY OUR HISTORICAL FOR THIS
BODY AS BOTH ALYSSA AND SUE
WILL ASSUME THE RESPECTIVE
ROLES AS THE FIRST WOMEN. TO BE
APPOINTED AS CHIEF SERGEANT AND
AS CHIEF CLERK. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE WAS
ESTABLISHED IN EIGHTEEN FORTY
NINE. AND A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE YEARS LATER WOMEN ARE STILL
GAINING MANY FIRST IN THIS
HOUSE. AS WE ENTER A NEW DECADE
REFLECT ON THESE FIRST AND
WITNESS TO WOMEN IN KEY LEADER
LEADERSHIP ROLES HELPING US
CONDUCT THE LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS OF THIS BODY. BOTH OF
THESE WOMEN HAVE LONG STANDING
CAREERS IN THEIR PROFESSIONS
AND BRING VALUABLE KNOWLEDGE
AND PERSPECTIVE TO OUR
INSTITUTION. THEIR APPOINTMENT
IS INSPIRING TO ALL OF US TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I CONGRATULATE
BOTH AND WELCOME ALYSSA BUCKLEY
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY AND OUR
CONTINUED WORK WITH C. PARKER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS AMAL
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS ASSEMBLY
REPUBLICAN LEADER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR SIXTY EIGHT. IT'S
A HISTORIC DAY FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY THAT WE ARE GATHERED
TO WITNESS THE SWEARING IN OF
BOTH THE FEMALE CHIEF CLERK AND
THE FEMALE SERGEANT AT ARMS.
THESE TWO WOMEN ARE BOTH
EMINENTLY QUALIFIED FOR THE
POSITIONS THAT THEY WILL NOW
ASSUME MS SUE PARKER. HAS ARE
HONORABLY AND SKILLFULLY SERVED
IN THE OFFICE OF THE CHIEF
CLERK. FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS AND MISS ALISSA BUCKLEY
HAS BEEN THIS HAS HAD A STELLAR
RECORD PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
WITH THE SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT I WISH YOU BOTH THE
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS IN YOUR NEW
ROLES AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WALDRON. SEEING MR
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANNA RISE
AND COMMEND THE SELECTION YOU
KNOW I THINK BACK TO PRIOR TO
PURSUE MY I'VE KNOWN AND WORKED
WITH JIM DRISKELL BRIAN COULD
BE OF COURSE DOTSON. PRIOR
CHIEF SERGEANT OF ARMS CHARLES
GREEN CHARLES BELL RONNIE PAIN
BRIAN- RICH DESMOND THESE ARE
OUTSTANDING EMINENTLY QUALIFIED
PEOPLE. OF THAT FIT WELL WITH
TWO DIVISIONS OF THIS BODY THE-
THE CALIBER OF PEOPLE INVOLVED
I THINK THE BRING AN
EXCEPTIONAL DEPT THE BACKGROUND
ACTUALLY A RICHER BACKGROUND IN
MANY RESPECTS. THEN WHAT ARE
THEIR PREDECESSORS HAD AS THEY
LAUNCHED OUT. SO I THINK THE
ANSWER OUTSTANDING CHOICES AND-
BUT FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
NOTED BRING GREAT BLUSTER THIS
BODY ON A HISTORIC DAY. THANK
YOU MISTER COOLEY. ST NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH. MEMBERS ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE I VOTE ON HR SIXTY EIGHT.
MEMBERS WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE. ON THIS HOUSE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. YOUR DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WELL. CLOSER ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES SEVENTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED
. MEMBERS I WILL NOW
ADMINISTER THE OATH OF OFFICE
TO EACH OF OUR NEW MEMBER
OFFICERS THE CHIEF KERR COLLECT
AND HER GAS MAY APPROACH THE
ROSTRUM NOW
. OKAY. FOR THE
OFFICE OF CHIEF CLERK REPEAT
AFTER ME HI HI STATE YOUR NAME
TO PARKER DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR THE
ONLY FULLER THAT I WILL SUPPORT
AND DEFEND THAT I WILL SUPPORT
AND DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC THAT I
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE BEAR TRUE FAITH
ALLEGIANCE TO THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES TO THE
POSITION OF THE UNITED. AND THE
CONSTITUTION STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA THAT I TAKE
THIS OBLIGATION FREELY THAT I
TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION
OR PURPOSE OF EVASION OUR
PURPOSE OF EVEN AND THAT I WILL
WELL AND FAITHFULLY AND THEN I
WILL- AND- URGED. PLEASE UPON
WHICH I AM ABOUT TO. ABOUT
GRADUATION THANK YOU VERY
.
THANK YOU. HER WHAT A DAY. WELL
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THIS INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY IN VOTER SUPPORT.
I'D LIKE TO THINK MY FAMILY FOR
ALL THE LOVE SUPPORT
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT THEY GIVE ME
I COULD NOT DO THIS WITHOUT YOU.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ARE MY
MOTHER PATRICIA WALKER. MY
HUSBAND CRAIG PARKER MY
DAUGHTER'S OUR DAUGHTERS.
NATALIE IN VICTORIA. AND THEN
MY SISTER AND FRIEND- TO THE
MARKET IS ALSO HERE WITH ME MY
BROTHER JONATHAN WAS UNABLE TO
MAKE IT NEITHER WAS MY SISTER
FAYE BUT I KNOW THAT THEY'RE
HERE WITH WITH ME IN OUR
THOUGHTS ALSO MY FATHER'S
UNABLE TO BE HERE BECAUSE HE
PASSED AWAY A FEW YEARS AGO BUT
I KNOW THAT HE IS JUST
EXTREMELY PROUD AND- JUMPING
FOR JOY UP. ABOVE I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THINK MANY OF MY FRIENDS
ENTER THROUGH HERE TODAY BUT-
TO NUMBER NUMEROUS TO NAME. BUT
I APPRECIATE APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOU. I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF THE
FAMILY CHIEF CLERK'S OFFICES
STATED EARLIER FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. WORKING HERE HAS
BEEN IT HAS BEEN AND CONTINUES
TO BE AN HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE
THE PRISON PROVIDE ME WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET AND WORK
WITH SOME AMAZING AND TALENTED
PEOPLE. AND OCCASIONALLY WHEN
IT'S A LITTLE HISTORY. I'VE HAD
MANY ROLES IN THE OFFICE- FROM
BEING THE FIRST FEMALE READING
CLERK. THE MINUTE CLERK. AND
MOST RECENTLY ASSISTANT CHIEF
CLERK. THE CHIEF CLERK'S OFFICE
HAS A LONG HISTORY AND LEGACY
OF PROVIDING OUTSTANDING
SERVICE TO THE MEMBERS. TO
THEIR STAFF AND TO THE PUBLIC.
AS A MEMBER OF THE CHIEF
CLERK'S OFFICE I WAS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN AND CONTRIBUTE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO BUILDING THAT
LEGACY OF EXCELLENCE THAT OUR
OFFICE IS KNOWN FOR. AS THE
CHIEF CLERK AND WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF MY DEDICATED
STAFF. IT IS MY GOAL TO BUILD
UPON THAT REPUTATION OF
PROVIDING EXCELLENT SERVICE.
SUPPORT COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING HIM SAFEGUARDING THE
INTEGRITY OF THIS INSTITUTION
AND TAKING US TO AS AN OFFICE
TO THE NEXT LEVEL. SO ONCE
AGAIN I THINK MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU
. GRADUATION STORE NEW
CHIEF CLERK SUE PARKER. MEMBERS
I WILL NOW MINISTER THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO THE CHIEF SERGEANT AT
ARMS ELECT MS BUCKLEY IN HER
GAS MAY APPROACH THE ROSTRUM
NOW. DID THIS. FOR THE OFFICE
OF CHIEF SERGEANT AT ARMS
REPEAT AFTER ME. I STATION DO
SOLEMNLY SWEAR. THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND. THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. STATE AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA AGAINST
ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC MEANS. THAT I WILL
BEAR TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE
TO THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES. AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT I TAKE THIS
OBLIGATION FREELY. APPLICATION
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION. AND THAT I WILL WELL
AND FAITHFULLY. I THINK
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES. UPON
WHICH I'M ABOUT TO ENTER. THE
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I AM TRULY
HUMBLED BY THIS OPPORTUNITY I'D
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF MY VERY
CLOSE FRIENDS THAT ARE ALL HERE
TODAY- WITHOUT YOU I WOULD NOT
BE HERE AND I TRULY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND- MISTER
SPEAKER A MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING THE CONFIDENCE
IN ME I PROMISE TO GIVE YOU A
HUNDRED AND 10% I'M VERY
EXCITED TO BE HERE AND TO BE A
MEMBER OF THE A CAPITAL CAN
MANY LOOK FORWARD TO SERVING
EACH OF YOU YOUR STAFF AND THE-
PEOPLE THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS IT IS
SIGNIFICANT THAT WE HAVE ACTED
TODAY TO INSTALL SU PARKER'S
CHIEF CLERK ANNALISA BUCKLEY AS
CHIEF SERGEANT OF ARMS NINETY
YEARS AGO THIS WEEK THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTED HAD A JEWEL
ANDERSON AS AN OFFICER OF THIS
HOUSE ANDERSON WHO IS TH
MINUTE PARK WAS THE FIRST WOMAN
ELECTED TO BECOME AN ASSEMBLY
OFFICER. THIS HAPPENED LESS
THAN SIX MONTHS AFTER THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT BECAME THE
LAW OF THE LAND. GUARANTEEING
WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE. WE
LIVE IN AN AGE WHERE WOMEN HOLD
MANY IMPORTANT OFFICES IN
CALIFORNIA. WOMEN'S WOMEN'S
SERVICE SENATE PRO TEM.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. STATE
CONTROLLER STATE TREASURER. U.
S. SENATOR AND SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES. IT IS
HARD TO BELIEVE AND SOMEWHAT
SHAMEFUL THAT THEIR NATION WIDE
VOTING RIGHTS TOOK EFFECT FEWER
THAN ONE HUNDRED YEARS AGO. IT
IS MORE SAMPLE THAT WE STILL DO
NOT HAVE A FAIR COMPLEMENT THE
WOMEN. IN THE SEATS IN FRONT OF
ME. WOMEN IN THIS HOUSE AND WE
SHOULD ALL WORK FOR THAT. IT IS
REFRESHING NOW TO SEE WOMEN
TAKE CHARGE OF THESE TO
ASSEMBLY OFFICES THAT I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN OCCUPIED BY MEN.
ONE OF THOSE. OFFICES SEEMS TO
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN OCCUPIED BY
ONE MAN DOTSON WILSON- BUT THE
HISTORIANS TELL ME THAT THERE
WERE OTHERS- LET'S ALSO NOTE
THAT THE ASSEMBLY THIRD NON
MEMBER OFFICE. CHAPLAIN IS ALSO
CURRENTLY HELD BY A WOMAN
REVENUE PATTY OSHA. CHIEF
CHEAPER TO PARKER DOTSON WILSON
SUCCESSOR HAS OUR STRONG
HISTORY IN THE ASSEMBLY. SHE
HAS WORKED IN THE CLERK'S
OFFICE FOR NEARLY THREE DECADES
AND IT SERVED AS ASSISTANT
CHIEF CAR FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE. GOING INTO THE FUTURE
WE CAN DEPEND ON TO PARKER TO
RUN THIS CRITICAL OFFICE WITH
AN EVEN HAND. DEEP KNOWLEDGE
WIDE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
INSTITUTION AND DEPENDABLE
LOYALTY FROM US THE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU CIVIC CONGRADULATIONS.
ON THE OTHER HAND CHIEF SURGEON
WAS A BUCKLEY IS A NEWCOMER TO
THE LEGISLATURE THAT DOES NOT
MEAN WE ARE LESS HAPPY TO HAVE
HER IN THIS POSITION WHICH
SEEMS TO GROW POURTANT AS AN
IMPORTANT SAYS STATE POLICY
CRITICS IN CALIFORNIA FIND NEW
WAYS AN OLD WAYS TO EXERCISE
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
CHIEF BUCKLEY COMES TO US WITH
AN EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT INCLUDING TWO
DECADES WITH THE SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT SHE WILL
DEMONSTRATE THAT EXPERIENCE
WORKING IN THIS BUILDING TO
ENSURE THAT LEGISLATORS CAPITAL
STAFF AND VISITORS ARE SAFE IS
WE PUBLIC WE CONDUCT THE
BUSINESS OF CALIFORNIA. I WAS A
BUCKLEY IS ALSO THE FIRST IN
PACIFIC ISLANDER CHIEF SERGEANT
IN OUR HISTORY. BY VIRTUE OF
OUR FILIPINO HERITAGE. ALYSSA
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANKS FOR
JOINING US IN THE ASSEMBLY.
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF OUR
NEW ASSEMBLY OFFICERS MEMBERS A
WELCOME RECEPTION FOR MEMBERS
FOR MEMBERS I WILL BE HELD
APPOINTED GERMANS OF SESSION
TODAY IN THE WILLIE BROWN
CONFERENCE ROOM TO HONOR OUR
NEW CHIEF SURGEON ARMS. AND ARE
NUDE CHIEF CLERK
. THANK YOU
MEMBERS ONE FINAL ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR OUR NEW OFFICERS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND GAS WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO. FOR THE
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE. ALL BILLS
HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED. THE
CONCERT. MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS I AM ORDERING THE
DEATHS TO BE HELD OPEN ON
FRIDAY JANUARY TENTH FOR THE
PURPOSE OF INTRODUCING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JANUARY TENTH NO FLOOR SESSION
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY JANUARY
THIRTEENTH. FLOOR SESSION IS AT
ONE PM IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED
THERE WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE ANY CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR OR TAKE YOUR
SEATS. WE ARE AT A GERMAN SOME
MEMORY
. MEMBERS WE ARE GERMANS
IN MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET
. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR
. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER BELOW
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS AYE
AYES TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED AND
THE LOVE ARTIST AND TEACHER
JOHN PAUL THE SORRY. A LITERAL
AND FIGURATIVE GIANT IN THE
WORLD OF ART HE STOOD SIX FEET
SEVEN INCHES TALL WITH A AT A
SHAGGY HAIR AND IN A AND A
BEARD MISTER BALL TO SORRY
PRODUCED THOUSANDS OF WORKS
MANY OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
EXHIBITED. AROUND THE WORLD AND
ARE IN THE COLLECTIONS OF MAJOR
MUSEUMS FROM LOS ANGELES TO NEW
YORK. AND AROUND THE WORLD.
JOHN PAUL JUST DIED LAST
THURSDAY AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
EIGHT AND HE WAS A PROLIFIC
ARTIST MAKING PAINTINGS
PHOTOGRAPHS BILLBOARDS VIDEOS
FILM SCULPTURES DIGITAL ARE
EVEN CREDIT CARDS IN AN IPHONE
APP. BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY
ONE IN NATIONAL CITY BALL THE
SORRY SHOWED INTEREST IN THE
ARTS WHILE HE WAS STILL YOUNG
BOY HIS SCHOOL TEACHERS
ACKNOWLEDGE HIS NATURAL
ARTISTIC ABILITIES OFTEN
PICKING HIM TO DO MURALS AND
SPECIAL PROJECTS AND- THAT
RECOGNITION GAVE HIM THE
COURAGE TO PURSUE ART. ALTHOUGH
HIS FATHER WORRIED THAT IT
WASN'T A FINANCIALLY PRACTICAL
CAREERS FATHER WOULD BE PROVEN
WRONG IN THAT INSTANCE THE-
BALL THE SORRY INFLUENCE DOZENS
OF ARTISTS BOTH WITH HIS WORK
AND IS A TEACHER AT CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE OF THE ARTS AND UCLA
WHILE TEACHING HE BUILT A
LEGACY OF. HERS SCULPTORS
PHOTOGRAPHERS SELECTION OF US
WHO WERE INSPIRED AS WORK BUT
FOUND THEIR OWN DIRECTION AS HE
ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO. OVER THE
DECADES HE COLLECTED NEW
DESIGNERS INCLUDING THE
NATIONAL MEDAL OF ARTS FROM
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. HIS WORK CAN
BE FOUND IN THE COLLECTIONS OF
NEW YORK'S MUSEUM OF MODERN ART
THE ART INSTITUTE OF CHICAGO
NEW YORK'S WHITNEY UGH A MUSEUM
OF AMERICAN ART THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUSEUM OF MODERN ART.
AND IN LOS ANGELES IS BROKE
MUSEUM THE MUSEUM OF
CONTEMPORARY ART. AND THE
COUNTY MUSEUM OF ART. PAUL TO
SORRY WAS AMONG THE EARLIEST
ARTISTS TO ENGAGE WITH IMAGE
CULTURE AND THE ONSLAUGHT OF
MASS MEDIA. HE WAS A RADICAL
AND A PROMINENT ARTIST ONE OUR
PROFESSOR SAID. HE POKED AT THE
ART WORLD HE POKED INSTITUTIONS
HE WAS UNAFRAID AND IRREVERENT
AND PLAYFUL AND HE WAS
COMMITTED TO TEACHING HIS
SURVIVORS INCLUDE TWO CHILDREN
AND A SISTER AND I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
MISTER SPEAKER MAY I CONTINUE
WITH MY SECOND INTERVIEW MAY
SIR THANK YOU UP MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF JOANNE BONNER LEVITT A LONG
TIME COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS IN THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND A
FRIEND OF MINE. JOANNE'S LIFE
LONG COMMITMENT TO ADVOCACY
LEFT A LASTING IMPACT ON HER
COMMUNITY IN OUR STATE IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES LOVE IT
WORKED WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO DEVELOP SOMETHING THAT WAS
THEN CONTRA OFFICIAL UGH THE
CONCEPT OF RAISING FUNDS AND
ESTABLISHING SHOWERS WASHERS
AND LOCKERS. FOR THE HOMELESS.
SINCE THEN SHE SUPPORTED
NUMEROUS CHARITABLE AND LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHOSE MISSIONS
MIRRORED HER OWN PASSION FOR
BETTERING EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AS WELL AS SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
JOANNE HELPED DALGLISH BOTH THE
ADDISON DUAL LANGUAGE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN SANTA
MONICA. EXCUSE ME AND THE SANTA
MONICA COLLEGE EARLY CHILDHOOD
CENTER PROVIDING RESIDENTS WITH
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO QUALITY
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. AND
THAT WILL TAKE PLACE IN A NEW
FACILITY THAT WILL SOON OPEN IN
SANTA MONICA. ADVOCACY WORK
ALSO HELP TRANSFORM SANTA
MONICA'S VIRGINIA AVENUE PARK
INTO A SAFE AND FUN LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT AND A COMMUNITY
MEETING PLACE FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. JOANNE'S LEADERSHIP
AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF ACTION
ADVOCACY FOR THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA LEAD
TO GREATER VOTER ENGAGEMENT IN
THE ELECTORAL PROCESS. HER
LEGACY OF COMMUNITY SERVICE
WILL CONTINUE TO POSITIVELY
IMPACT THE LIVES OF FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS SHE
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY
SECOND AND IS SURVIVED BY HER
TWO SONS TWO GRANDCHILDREN AND
TWO GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND
ASKS THAT YOU JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY. IN THE MEMORY OF
JOANNE WAGNER LOVE IT THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN MEMORY. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. TODAY I
RISE THE GERMAN IN THE MEMORY
OF A TREMENDOUS COMMUNITY AND
BUSINESS LEADER HELP MAKE
HERALDED GREW UP IN MOUNT
YOKOHAMA STARTED THE CAR
BUSINESS IN OKLAHOMA CITY AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY. THE BIGGEST
FOR THE NINETEEN TO JOIN HIS
BROTHER AND SOON OPERATED A
USED CAR LOT LOCATE ON CHESTER
AVENUE AND A VOLKSWAGEN
DEALERSHIP ON COLUMBUS AVENUE.
HELL JOINED THREE WAY CHEVROLET
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE.
INITIALLY PARTNERING WITH THE
CORMIER FAMILY INSERTED THE
DEALER OPERATOR ANGELES
RETIREMENT IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. IT WAS A
NATURAL LEADER PASSIONATE ABOUT
HELPING OTHERS AND INSPIRING
THE NEXT GENERATION. HE STARTED
THE GREATER BAKERSFIELD NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION SCHOLARSHIP
FUND IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX WHICH NOW
OPERATES AN ENDOWMENT. A MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND GIVES NUMEROUS
SCHOLARSHIPS TO STUDENTS IN THE
BIXEL AREA. COMMITTED TO
SERVICE HELD SERVE ON SEVERAL
FOUNDATION AND NONPROFIT BOARDS.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA NEW
CAR GET THOSE ASIAN THE BIG SO
POLICE DEPARTMENTS SECRET WHAT
IS PROGRAM WAS AVID SUPPORTER
BIXEL COLLEGE. OVER THE YEARS
MAKE WAS ALSO ON SEVERAL BOARDS
SO SHE WOULD GENERAL MOTORS.
OWING INPART TO THREE WAY
CHEVROLETS LONG RUN. AS THE
COMPANY'S LARGEST VOLUME
DEALERSHIP. L. WITH A GIANT IN
AN ICON IN OUR COMMITTEE. HELD
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE KAY WHO
HAS SERVED TWENTY YEARS AS A
TRUSTEE FOR THE KERN COUNTY.
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THEIR THREE CHILDREN SON MARK
DAUGHTERS JOINED AT THE END AS
WELL AS FOR GRAND CHILDREN.
WELL TO BE GREATLY MISSED AND I
AM GRATEFUL TO THIS MAN. I WAS
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO
RECENTLY CATCH UP WITH HAROLD
AT THE WEDDING OF HIS GRANDSON
JORDAN DECEMBER. HE WAS A
MENTOR AND ROLE MODEL BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY HE WAS MY FRIEND
AND I ASKS THAT WE HONOR HIS
TREMENDOUS LEGACY AND INJURING
HIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER I'LL. MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
RISE TODAY TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
GEORGE STURGEON THE BILL OF
HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL
BASKETBALL COACH AND MY FORMER
COACH. PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
SEVENTEENTH HE WAS EIGHTY THREE.
COASTERS AND WAS DESCRIBED AS
NOT JUST A BRILLIANT COACH
BILLS WILL ALSO A MAN OF FAITH.
WHO IS REVERED BY MANY WHO
PLAYED FOR HIM AND KNEW HIM.
COACH STURGEON WAS NOT JUST A
COACH BUT A MENTOR AND FOR MANY
A FATHER FIGURE. HILL DESPITE
OUR FAITH. AND WE'RE ALL ACTIVE
IN THE FELLOWSHIP OF CHRISTIAN
ATHLETES. HE ALSO TAUGHT US.
ABOUT THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE HE
OPENED ABOUT UP ABOUT HIS
CULTURE ABOUT HIS LIFE ABOUT
HIS HERITAGE. POSTERS AND GREW
UP IN PASADENA AS BOTH A
BASKETBALL AND TENNIS PLAYER.
WELL A PAST IN HIGH SCHOOL IN
PASADENA CITY COLLEGE IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES. AFTER PLAN IT
PASSED IN HIGH SCHOOL AND PCC
TEARS IN PLAYED AT WESTMONT
COLLEGE BECOMING THE THIRD ALL
TIME LEADING SCORER. AT THAT
TIME. AS A COACH HE LED PASSING
A HIGH SCHOOL BOYS BASKETBALL
TEAMS TO SEE AYE OF SOUTHERN
SECTION CHAMPIONSHIPS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. AND
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. THE ONE
ON WHICH AT PASADENA CITY
COLLEGE AND LED THEM TO SEVEN
CONSECUTIVE STATE PLAYOFF
APPEARANCES INCLUDING THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO STATE TITLE
GAME. BECAUSE OF HIS SUCCESS AS
AN ATHLETE. AND A COACH HE HAS
RECEIVED MANY ACCOLADES.
INCLUDING BEING INDUCTED INTO
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA INTER
INTER SCHOLASTIC BASKETBALL
COACHES ASSOCIATION IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THE WESTMONT
COLLEGE HALL OF FAME IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
MEN'S BASKETBALL COACHES
ASSOCIATION HALL OF FAME IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. AND THE PASS IN A
SPORTS HALL OF FAME IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HE WAS
INDUCTED INTO THE PCC SCHOOL
HALL OF FAME AS WELL. HE'S BEEN
DESCRIBED BY FORMER PLAYERS AS
THE ULTIMATE COACH HAVING
CHARACTER WITHOUT PEER. AND
AHEAD OF HIS TIME. BY HIS
EXAMPLE IN THROUGH HIS WORDS HE
TAUGHT PLAYERS HOW TO SUCCEED
ON THE COURT AND IN LIFE. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE THE NIDA
SON TODD AND DAUGHTER MELISSA.
FOR THESE REASONS I ASKED THAT
W ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISS HOLDEN. I MISTER
PATTERSON HERE RECOGNIZE FOR
GERMANY MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS UP I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY
FOR CAROLINE DEVORE WEST. SHE
WAS A BELOVED TO TALENT AGENT
MANAGER AN ACTING COACH AN
INDEPENDENT CASTING DIRECTOR IN
HOLLYWOOD AND IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA. SHE PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY ON DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN. LIVING
IN BASS LAKE CALIFORNIA THE
FINAL YEARS OF HER LIFE BEFORE
CAROLINE BECAME A TALENT AGENT
SHE LIVED A STORIED LIFE AS A
SUCCESSFUL MODEL AND ACTRESS.
SHE WAS A GUEST ON MANY VARIETY
SHOWS LIKE THE D. MARTIN CHAU
STEVE ALLEN SHOW AND ON JOHNNY
CARSON. CAROLINE WAS A DEVOTED
SUPPORTER OF OUR ARMED SERVICES
SHE ENTERTAINS SOLDIERS IN
VIETNAM DURING SEVERAL U. S.
TOURS WITH BOB HOPE SOME OF HER
PROUDEST MOST ENJOYABLE
MEMORIES. HER LIFE'S TRUE
CALLING THOUGH AND PARTICULARLY
AROUND THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
AREA WAS AS A TALENT AGENT AND
SCOUT FOR THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN
AND YOUNG ADULTS SHARING HER
HOLLYWOOD EXPERIENCES WITH-
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR ALMOST. THIRTY
YEARS FOR MANY SHE WAS MORE
THAN AN AGENT SHE WAS FAMILY.
CAROLYN IS SURVIVED BY HER
DAUGHTER HEATHER- SON RALEIGH
AND HUSBAND OF THIRTY ONE YEARS
JOHN WEST- WE MOURN HER PASSING
BUT WE FINALLY REMEMBER HER
LIFE IN OUR MIDST AND WE ASK
THAT YOU WOULD GERMAN. IN HER
MEMORY THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK
YOU MISS PATTERSON. MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL REQUESTS TO
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. OR OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING HEARING OF FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
MISTER. HOLDEN MOVES MISTER
PATTERSON SECONDS. AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY JANUARY THIRTEENTH. AT
ONE PM WE ARE ADJOURNED